ladies and gentlemen the year of siege
is upon us after months of hype weeks of
testing and just over seven days of live
action we have finally been able to
start formulating real cogent thoughts
about rainbow six's newest craziest
operator to date a death match mode
attackery pick and a sea of universally
applicable weapon sites
the year that's supposed to save siege
is here
it's happening we're in it
the question
is is it any good
[Music]
okay so before i start gushing endlessly
about demon veil i must humbly ask that
all of you siege heads out there do me
and yourselves a favor and like
subscribe and turn on notifications the
better that our siege content does the
more of it they're going to let me make
and trust me
i really want to make more of it all
right let's dive in so for those of you
who've been so busy checking your night
market or whatever that you've actually
missed the news a new season has finally
dawned upon the beautiful chronically
busted shooter that is rainbow six siege
and let me tell you
it's the one we've been waiting for
demon veil now i already went over
what's included in this season and the
year 7 road map at large in my post si
recap video so if you're in need of a
full comprehensive preview be sure to
check it out in the meantime let's focus
on the here and now since from what i
gather a lot of you started reinstalling
siege once you heard the demon veil was
going to bring us back from the brink of
despair and are in need of a rundown of
sorts so let's start with the little
stuff
like the web insights after years of
watching the community beg ubisoft
finally made it so that all one-time
sites are universal this means that all
versions of the hollow red dot and
reflex sights are available for all
operators oh and the russian acog is
available for those who have acog of
course there's tons of debate as to
which is the so-called
god site that everyone should start
immediately equipping on everything and
while i am hearing a lot of people gass
up the russian red dot and reflex
i
am all in on the vortex the second the
update went live i slapped hollow b on
everything and never looked back i have
loved this site since they launched it
and have been absolutely slamming with
it on the smg 11. this site is a beast
and i do not care who says otherwise but
it's all about preference and
as heeded as the discussions as to which
is better have been getting
you love to see it
i know it's like a really little thing
but anyone who plays a lot of siege will
tell you it makes a big difference
people are really psyched about this
change and i honestly think that it's
one of the best quality of life
implementations that ubisoft has made in
a long time next the death match mode
look here's the deal at first
i really didn't like it it kind of felt
to me like ubisoft failed to emulate the
cs go community deathmatch experience in
the same way that riot did and that just
irked me to no end and then the more i
played it the more i started to
appreciate it not as like a raw aim
warm-up but rather as a sort of round
simulator where every life is treated as
its own distinct take or execute or
flank watch or what have you if you
haven't tried it you should it's really
cool and i've actually been playing a
ton of it
especially since it's a very easy way to
secure battle pass levels
speaking of the battle pass this is bar
none the best battle pass siege has ever
had like literally all of the skins are
bangers
especially that hibana set i never knew
that i needed to see mama heeby in a
leather jacket motorcycle helmet and
space age mom jeans
but that is certifiable queen [ __ ] as
for the ranked features like phone
verification and the new anti-toxicity
measures they're awesome and i'm super
glad they're here but honestly
it's a little too early to tell how much
of an impact they'll actually have i
feel like these are the kinds of changes
that will have good impact long term
and so we'll just have to wait and see
what else
oh
ah
attacker re-pick for those who don't
know attackers can now re-pick their
operators up until the end of the drone
phase but the reveal phase has been
removed
this means that you have to risk drones
to see what the enemy team is running
and draft accordingly personally and
this is just my opinion
i think that this has the ability to
change siege for the better
i also think that we need to see it in
action for an elongated period of time
before we can form any fruitful or
worthwhile opinions on it last but
certainly not least
the reason that a lot of you are
probably watching this video
a zombie i'm sure you've all heard the
stories about how siege's newest
defender boasts five bulletproof wall
sized discs that spawn out of her super
bad ass knives and that she is the
coolest deepest most game-changing
operator ever to grace the roster of the
six and let me be the first
or what's more likely the 71st to tell
you
that she most certainly is after only
one week of experimenting with her i can
safely say that there is no limit to the
kinds of pickles that a zombie's kit can
both create
and get you out of
i'm coming back just come back today we
don't need to peek it what are we doing
smoking it off good [ __ ]
from closing off breaches hatches and
doorways to closing off sight lines to
creating these weird dumb off angles
this operator is essentially a one size
fits all wrecking ball of expressive
utility driven ownage
i ran her on border the other day and
let me tell you she is a terror if you
play around security it feels like it's
your world and the attackers are just
living in it
nice but god knows there are hundreds if
not thousands of downright toxic
hole-ups and one-ways she's able to
establish
i have already been privy to some
absolutely cursed site setups like [ __ ]
that is going to make attackers want to
straight up alt tab out of ranked
site
oh what the i can't hold the big one to
jump in oh you're so good
there does seem to be a feeling that she
might be a little too strong i do think
five kibas is probably a tad excessive
but we obviously won't know how viable
she is until she's unquarantined for pro
play until then hop into a custom game
screw on your thinking cap and start
experimenting she is a lot of fun oh and
of course there's also the new map
emerald planes which i have not had a
chance to try and have no thoughts about
since it hit the test server like 24
hours ago but tons of other creators are
already sharing their thoughts so be
sure to check them out so is demon veil
delivering on the promise to initiate
the so-called year of siege
i mean
honestly
yeah
it is
look would i have loved to see an
ironclad anti-cheat released day one
of course but these things take time and
i still love siege enough
that i'm willing to wait for now i am
relishing in the fact that this season
is in fact a bang if you're one of those
people who's wondering whether you
should smash or pass
it's a smash for sure
i am having a ball with virtually
everything this season has to offer
and i can't wait to see what else this
year has in store
next jesus
that was very high the best battle pass
we've ever had no cap literally all of
the skins i don't i can't i can't say no
cap
on camera danny who do i think i am what
do i think i'm doing here i'm 29 years
old daddy i can't say no cap listen one
day one day there's gonna be pensioners
saying